I know you said it's a small nation
somewhere in the Middle East
but it also happens to be the epicenter
of one of the longest running one of the
most tense conflicts and crises in human
history so at the very least it serves
as a study of how conflict can be
resolved so what are the biggest
obstacles to you
uh to achieving peace in this part of
the world
motivation I think it's easy to achieve
peace if you have the motivation on both
on both sides unfortunately the present
juncture there is not enough motivation
on either side either the Palestinian or
Israeli studying peace
you know in mathematics you have
problems without Solutions you can prove
mathematically that this mathematical
problem has no solution
in politics there is no such thing all
problems have Solutions if you have the
motivation
and but motivation is the big problem
and again we can go into the reasons why
but the fact is that on neither side is
there enough motivation if there was
motivation the solution would have been
easy is there an important distinction
to draw between the people on the street
and the leaders
in power in terms of motivation so
are most people
uh motivated and hoping for peace and
the leaders are motivated and
incentivized to continue War I don't
think so or the people also I think it's
it's a deep problem it's also the people
it's not just the leaders is it even a
human problem of literally hate in
people's heart yeah there is a lot of
hate one of the things that happened in
Israel over the last 10 years or so
Israel became much stronger than it was
before largely thanks to technological
developments and it feels that it no
longer needs to compromise
that and this is there are many reasons
for it but some of them are
technological uh being one of the
leading
powers in cyber in AI in in high tech
we have developed
very sophisticated ways to more easily
control the Palestinian population
in the early 2000s it seemed that it is
becoming impossible to control millions
of people against the will it took too
much power it spilled too much blood on
both sides
uh so there was an impression oh this is
becoming untenable
and there are several reasons why it
changed but one of them was new
technology Israel developed very
sophisticated surveillance technology
that has made it much easier
for Israeli Security Forces to control
2.5 million Palestinians in the West
Bank against their will
uh with a lot less effort less boots on
the ground also less blood
and uh Israel is also now exporting this
technology to many other regimes around
the world
um again I heard Netanyahu speaking
about all the wonderful things that
Israel is exporting to the world and
it's true we are exporting some nice
things
water systems and and to make new kinds
of tomatoes we are also exporting a lot
of weapons and especially uh
surveillance systems sometimes to
unsavory regimes in order to control
their populations